patience is not a virtue
it is a weapon what's your wow rabbit and you
can see how these two super grand masters made
their way to the final hikaru nakamura beat levon
panzolia then edged out paramag sulu the top seed
in a boat game video guzrati has been
unscathed in the knockout beating alexey
roshini and then sweeping chakra momojarov a bit
of a surprise there mama jarov is a superstar but
in the first game it was getting to a position
towards the end game and well it looks like
his tactics were sharper and then game two
as well in the time scramble it was vidit who
looked like the powerful player that he is
and now he gets to face as his reward hikaru
nakamura for first place in this knockout both
these two players stellar ambassadors of the
game of chess been streaming a ton lately made
it on youtube echo on twitch and we are just
making sure that the players are set up and i'll
be getting the word on who gets white in the
first game remember it is a two game mini match
of three minute plus one second increment and
um looks like hikaru is taking the
white pieces if i'm not mistaken so
hopefully these games take off
soon and we'll get to the chess
because you know me i'm always excited for some
awesome speed chess great games to commentate on
and well that it is just looking to upset if you
will another super grandmaster back to back so
you know it's hard to say in these uh online chess
events because vidin is a powerhouse himself but
mama jarv in terms of least over-the-board chess
has the higher of two ratings and uh i was wrong
nick hegar has black to start with so he gets
black in the first game and so vidit will try to
prove the first move advantage here try to
take an initiative you do not want to lose
with the white piece as we saw you know we've
seen what happens in those cases you lose the
white and you somehow win with black not so
easy so forbid it you want to make the most of
this in the opening game and for hikaru well
you're kind of chilling we saw his approach
against para maxudo two draws are okay with
him because he is the favorite in the bullet
so we are going to have the games begin right
now here we are so bit it y pieces plays d4 i
saw him do the same against mama jarv and will
we get a king's indian no we will not we will get
maybe a nim zone let's see how pita continues
here knight c3 typical bishop b4 after that
no we see knight f3 and d5 so we have the qgd
and we're going to get a catalan here we go the
bishop on the long diagonal please take me on c4
that's what has been asked and answered sure you
asked me to i will so this bishop on g2 would
love to remove that bishop on c6 out of the way
but the problem is not easy to do that you're not
going to accomplish that and this is the line i
believe where black takes an f3 and plays c6 so
you take on f3 the bishop takes back you play
c6 and you claim that you have a brick wall on
the queen side here it is exactly the sequence
and opposite color bishops white has slightly
more space but black has great control over
this b4 square so that's the good news for black
control the b4 square no targets to exploit but
white just has more space and considering how
quickly vit has been playing this i feel like
maybe he has a little something up his sleeve here
because black generally speaking shuffles around a
bit it doesn't really do much of anything you
know if you play you can't play c5 that opens
up the bishop you can think about playing e5 but
that has ramifications that you'll have to deal
with as well so hikaru i think we'll put a work
on d8 maybe f to d8 keep this rook on a8 he plays
e5 okay i thought d5 now is the move because
takes bishop takes and what ideally you get
is if this black knight takes you on d5 you end
up putting your own knight on the light square
and this bishop on d6 can't attack you so that's
exactly what we're seeing maybe maybe there was
a potential for knight c3 first but instead it
takes back on d5 that was the first one i said
bishop can go back to g2 and now the light square
bishop is better than knight so that's the problem
for black in these seven positions it's not that
white is much better but why is a little pull
no matter the trades that we get if you take on c
three minute night gets there i have a slight pull
thanks to the quality of my bishop on g2 and now
if i go knight d5 this could be a slightly better
bishop of opposite color intense queen and
rook's middle game because the problem on f7
is greater than any problem that white has
but black is still holding in all these lines
and you have to try knight d5 though and
there are the sirens i know there they go um
it's not for any players chances here looks
pretty fine so far hey car looking like he's
having to time his life cracking
up i don't know what that's about
so a car is having a blast and vidit seems
to be really laser focused on the center
of the board here and i guess that's
what it was about he decides to trade
one pair of rooks and this rook would love to get
to c6 and start trying to get in the position but
bishop c5 now says nope no progress for you and
the pawn can be e4 to reinforce his bishop to
keep it solidly in place but we play e4
black could play f5 and say hey my bishop
is now opened up as well so i think this game
in all likelihood will be a draw i think they'll
split the point i'm not quite sure how white
intends to improve the position from this point
f7 is defended queen defends
b6 you can play bishop e7 or
d8 you can play e4 and check the queen to f3 check
i don't see what did it could possibly
do here i think it's totally fine
so bishop e7 allows for work to d8 next
and swapping the rooks results in immediate
quality uh rookie 6 rook d6 as well
nice and if rook d7 you play rook e7
if rookie 6 or d6 you can try to do that
rookie 6 rook d7 there still is rook d6
because you can take on f7 with check but i can
take you back because once this rook gets to d6
it's a problem down the d file sorry i
dropped the rook on the square it means to
play bishop e7 going for the rook swap next
move and i think we'll see a draw green
i'm doing well thank you for asking see you
see you on the chat thanks for everybody who's
tuned in right now we just have two games to go
this one uh and if we get a winner in the next
one then it's all over or we go to a bullet
tiebreaker and the first to win a bullet game
wins the match so vivid is trying to
pretend like he has something here
but it's a whole lot of nothing the queen and
the bishop doing a great job of covering these
pawns aren't dark squares which means the bish1c4
can't get there okay these pieces all under attack
but so what how can you make progress here maybe
f4 at some point doesn't look real plays it
and this queen can probably continue
to go back and forth from e7 to c7 so
h4 takes do not take with the queen that's how you
drop a pawn and that could be a problem even there
actually isn't so bad the nature of the opposite
color bishops should be totally fine for black
stakes with bishop of course
and now white is up a pawn
so he's pretending hey i've got
the extra pawn all is good here
but the queen still come to e7 and maybe into
f6 that pawn moves the queen can come into g5
yeah this is nothing hold on nothing and i wonder
if carl could start thinking about playing for a
win because he is well ahead in the clock and
you know if at a certain point you realize hey
i can't really lose so why don't i play on
and try to see if i can swindle one wouldn't
be that surprised like queen f5 here trying to
get over to c2 perhaps e4 not an easy move to
play when you give up more of the dark squares or
queen f3 queen c2 check king f1 yeah it's a draw
both players know that it's a draw but no
harm in trying to just steal a victory and
no he'll trade enough to now i think yeah he
realizes there's nothing here and draw agreed
okay so game two now if there's a winner the
match is over if they draw their game we get
a bullet game to decide this we're getting oh is
he taking the bullet he car did this on purpose
he wants bullet and you could see him trying
to hold back a smile and vidit's like oh no
oh no oh no here we go here here's the the draw
that everybody has seen many times car did this
against magnus if he feels like it favors him
to get rid of this game he's going to do it
and it does favor him because we get the bullet
so for vita gujarati he can enjoy his couple
rating points that he earned from this draw but
he's probably not thrilled about entering the
bullet and you see him taking a deep breath
there stretching the neck it all comes down
to this bullet game unless they draw
in which case we get more bullet
here comes the 1-0 all right get it with the
black pieces will we see a car go for e4 oh
what just happened
okay i guess car wasn't ready and does vinnie get
the white pieces because he was the higher seed
right wasn't it car er evaded the three seed
and no if it was a seven seed ah okay never
mind if it was a seven see the car was the four
seat uh so he car gets choice that makes sense
for some reason my head bit it was the three
c because they all tied first to eighth place
with eight and a half out of ten but i i was
remembering incorrectly i think i thought that
mama jarv was the two and then it was a three
but that was definitely not the case okay
and the game has started hit carp was e4 we have
are we getting the berlin i doubt it no we get
this antsy delayed exchange uh spanish here and
anthony berlin and video needs to move quickly
he needs to move well of course but he needs to
move quickly and i think that's going to be his
biggest problem right now a car is going to use
time as a weapon and knight g5 doesn't have to do
anything this is protect you just take back and
what's the situation whoa hung up on did it one
upon the center that was huge and vivid needs to
fight quickly because he is up a clean pawn right
now and he brings queen back to e6 he wants to
play f6 to keep his f5 no he's going aggressive
here and vin is actually ahead in the clock wow
the car blundered the e4 pawn and now can you play
e4 can you just push that through no he doesn't do
it i'm wondering when e4 is possible but he this g
pawn is hanging in many variations because a5
which both allows a4 gives his king an outlet
and now with g5 he's playing on both sides of the
board here okay and hikaru is even on the clock
so when is e4 going to happen the queen can be
exchanged on d5 but that fixes this pawn structure
as we enter the late middle game stages do not
take on f4 that blunders the rook on e6 but vid
is using too much time and his position is great
but i don't like his clock management right now
e4 what's this it's nice not hanging knight c4
what's going on here queen takes f4 is there
some kind of he takes d3 because the back rank
mate no the queen covers on g1 so he brings me
back to c7 he just does not not have enough time
i don't think he's going to be really trying to
save this one but his clock is not good no
no no no no his clock is really bad for him
yeah there's gonna be a win for a car i feel like
oh d2 what just happened there and now it's hikaru
taking d2 next but don't take this away because
queen 61 so he takes this one he's queen g1
that is precision by hikaru and he's going to
win on the board he wins on the clock hikaru
nakamura takes this speed chess championship
grand prix it was a blunder in the early
stages too did it stole a pawn and a karu
just said yeah okay i blundered it happens
right down the center here the queen is behind the
pawn so you can't take it back and still won the
game so what a performance by akara nakamura even
when it looks like he's in trouble we're going to
take a our last break and when we turn we'll bring
hikaru on get a quick interview with the speed
chess championship grand prix winner and we are
back with the speech champion grand prix winner
hikar nakamura so i have to congratulate you
first and foremost for qualifying for the speed
chess championship aren't you proud of yourself
one second i apparently have to mute my zoom
yeah okay can you hear me now
i can hear you can you hear me
no can't hear me all right nicara way way
i'm doing something wrong one second um
yeah i think we're good now so gotcha all right
go ahead go ahead i was congratulating you on
as a joke for qualifying for the speed chess
championship because you did win the speech
champion grand prix like the total series mean
just you're a monster like you just nobody can
stop you how do you do it um you know i i mean i
think in general uh i i think in general um mainly
what i would say is that you just play every
game do you take it one game at a time basically
okay well how about the your decision in the final
you made that quick draw which you've done before
when you think it optimizes your winning chances
against vidit you just said let's make a draw and
head to bullet so that looked like a little bit of
foresight by you yeah i mean i think the thing is
is that i felt against probably against vida and
parham specifically they're two of the best blitz
players like who i could play against and um and
so if i have the opportunity to go into bullet i
probably should be a bigger favorite there than
i'm going to be in being blitz right and you
certainly proved that to be the case and when you
dropped that pawn against a vetted there were you
concerned about the result or did you feel like
you would be able to bounce back because that
was a pretty important pawn objectively in the
position yeah i mean i think at that point i was
i was a little bit um discombobulated everything
was kind of going weird cuz i tried to run an
ad and then like they started the game right away
then there was on board then i tried to make a
move and the game started like five seconds later
it was all pretty pretty random but i think again
in bullet more so than blitz you just you just
make moves and i felt that um actually the game
against vedic wasn't the one that i thought was
close i think the game against parham was the one
um where he thought for too long there was this
critical moment in the middle game where i think
he used like 20 seconds or 15 15 to 20 seconds
for two moves and that was the game where he was
up on time and was very very complicated and
i think that one was objectively a little bit
closer and tighter than the one against vedic so
i just kept making moves against veda and he just
couldn't keep up with the flow yeah and obviously
both of them are very strong players but so how do
you train that like how do you force yourself to
make a move yours just said an example of it was
complicated he was a little ahead in time but then
he spent 20 seconds so how can you force yourself
to play a good move quickly rather than try to
find the absolute best move i mean it's bullet
just time is money as the saying goes and um you
just try to move quickly and i i think in general
um like the one good thing about positioning
against veda especially was that the the way
the position was i didn't really have many things
to consider i had try to like maneuver my knight
to c4 or play like f4 when he tries g4 h4 on the
king's side and so the fact that i didn't really
have many moves to consider i think really helped
me in terms of just just playing moves because
there isn't much to do i'm down upon and much
worse but you just make moves and hopefully your
opponent isn't as fast or they make some mistakes
and indeed it uh he just wasn't wasn't quite fast
enough at the end there yeah and he car throughout
the speeches champions grand prix you won five
knockout brackets so pretty impressive there did
you keep track or did you is that a surprise to
you no i didn't keep track i mean the thing is
most of the ones that i played in i felt were at
least two of them were very random where i got off
to a bad start i had to win like four or five in a
row at the end to to get into the um to get into
in into the knockout so i knew i had won quite a
few i didn't didn't really pay close attention
to it though so um you know you just play and
i i felt it i feel like in the head-to-head
especially the format of bullet at the end
um generally speaking i should be the favorite
against probably anybody and i think i kind of
proved that based on how many of the knockouts i
won okay my final question for you is now we know
four more players who are taking part in the speed
chess championship based on their grand priest
endings and those are artemiev nuribek abutarov
parham magsudalu and hike martirosian of well i
think are you going to say our 10 meetups i'll
exclude him for the time being which of those
players has the best chance of registering an
upset in the speed chess championship i mean
you say upset i'm not sure that i would say our
tamiya is an underdog that's why that's why i took
him out of the equation i i would also make the
argument i'm not honestly sure that parham is an
underdog either out of those four guys um so yeah
i guess what i would say is in general um those
first two i don't think are gonna be really be
underdogs i think probably notrebeck is is the one
who's most likely to cause an upset um though out
of that group of four because i consider par ham
and artemia to be at least even if not favorites
when they who whomever they uh go up against the
speech championship so even if they're playing
somebody like mvl or wesley you say that they're
about level toss-up i mean i think parham and and
um parham and vladislav the other but they're both
very strong players i think it's close they might
be slight underdogs but they're not going to be
big underdogs okay now that's you know some high
praise we know from our 10 yeah he's made the
semi-finals before that's no surprise but i guess
uh by feed a classical rating it's a different
story than when you get to the online especially
these quicker time controls so hikaru you know
gotta thank you for joining us to interview and
congratulate you once more you are the champion
of the speeches champion grand prix you're the
reigning speeches champion so a lot of titles
to bestow upon you and we're very appreciative
of your time yeah thank you that's fun all right
and there you have it the final standings of
the speed chess champion grand prix hikaru
nakamura finishes in a dominant first 137.5
points he made just as many points from the
knockout bonus as he did from the swiss score and
that's the difference look at that i mean you have
the players right after him artemia ferocious
abductor and parham maxoudlu they all scored
almost as much as hikar did as their swiss base
score but it was where in the knockout where
hikaru was just an absolute monster winning five
of them and that's where his bonuses came from in
artemyev he qualifies feroceae has already made
his way through by virtue of finishing second
place in the speeches championship super swiss
so kara won that ferocious gets the second spot
and that allows heike marchi roshun to sneak
in as the fourth qualifier from the grand prix
in addition to nerdy back abductor and parham
magsudu and reminded everybody that there will
be more qualification spot on the line there's
one in the speed chess invitational which will
be happening in the near future you should you
know follow chess.com social media to find out
when that will be follow the news reports but it
has not yet been confirmed as the date but 1250
first place prize as well as the qualification to
speed chess championship and how else could you
get the speeches championship well most of the
spots are away the top four from the grand prix
the winner of the super swiss which ended up
being fedor save and second nihal sarin from the
jscc and that leaves one spot up for qualification
grabs in the speedchest championship invitational
on that note the grand prix has come to a
conclusion it's been a really fun series of events
hikaru nakamura week in week out no matter who he
faces no matter if he drops an early game or not
he finds his way to the top and he is a worthy
champion we gotta give all the credit in the world
to kara nakamura it's a bit of gujarati today
for making it such a fun fight making it to the
bullet tiebreaker where did it stole upon but just
couldn't keep up on the clock and so okaru won it
and that's all from chess.com for this speech of
champion grand prix i'm grand master robert hess
until next time keep enjoying the chest
stay safe and have a good one everybody